.
Ihr kennt das: Man will einfach
im Internet ein bisschen entspannen.
Doch dann gerät man in eine
Kommentar-Spalte (- Was?) und:
Uaaaaah!!!!
Freunde der Sonne, willkommen zu:
"Wie man Bullshit erkennt, Teil 2:
Die häufigsten Scheinargumente."
Diskussionen
können uns schnell triggern.
Aaah!
Manchmal sind es
persönliche Meinungen:
Wer Pfeifhasen nicht süß findet,
ist ein Monster!
(Pfeifen)
Manchmal ist es
die Art der Argumentation:
Wo ist hier die Logik?
Das macht doch keinen Sinn!
- Du meinst: "Das ergibt
keinen Sinn?" - Halt die Fr... !
Letzte Woche sprachen wir über
die Regeln für kritisches Denken.
Heute machen wir,
wenn man so will, das Gegenteil.
Die Frage ist nämlich:
Wie sollte kritisches Denken
nicht aussehen?
Wir lassen uns
wieder inspirieren von:
"The Fine Art of Baloney Detection",
"Die hohe Kunst,
Bullshit zu erkennen",
aus Carl Sagans Klassiker
"The Demon-Haunted World".
"Baloney", oder Bullshit,
beruht oft auf Scheinargumenten
oder Logikfallen,
die Carl Sagan hier auflistet.
Die Liste ist relativ lang,
aber trotzdem nicht,
wie er auch selbst schreibt,
vollständig. Es gibt noch viel mehr!
Aber deswegen möchte ich auch selbst
keinen Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit
hier erheben,
sondern in diesem Video
die 8 häufigsten Logikfallen
hier rausziehen,
die sich meiner Meinung nach v.a.
in Internet-Kommentarspalten finden.
Ihr habt 'n Tee?
Dann kann's losgehen!
(Titelmelodie)
Untertitel: ARD Text für Funk (2018)
Nr.1:
Es sollte keinen Unterschied machen,
ob ein Argument auf einem neutralen
Blatt Papier geschrieben steht
oder ob eine Person
dieses Argument vorträgt.
Trotzdem neigen wir dazu,
die Person da mit reinzuziehen.
"Ad hominem",
kurz für "argumentum ad hominem",
bezieht sich auf ein Argument,
das sich nicht
auf den Streitpunkt bezieht,
sondern auf die Person,
mit der ich streite.
Ein Beispiel: Sagen wir,
die Diskussion geht um Sexismus.
(Schlürfen)
Dann sind beliebte
Ad-hominem-Argumente z.B.:
"Sorry, aber Feminazis kann ich
nun mal nicht ernst nehmen!"
Oder:
"Sorry, aber als weißer Cis-Mann,
kannst du schön die Klappe halten!"
Argumente über Sexismus
müssen auch unabhängig
von der Person funktionieren,
die diese Argumente vorträgt.
Auch ein beliebtes
Ad-hominem-Argument wäre so was:
"Du brauchst mir gar nichts zu
den Risiken von Alkohol zu erzählen,
So viel wie du säufst!"
Ein Argument gegen Alkohol
sollte unabhängig sein
von der Person,
die dieses Argument vorträgt.
Wenn ihr also das nächste Mal
in den Kommentaren
persönlich angegriffen
oder beleidigt werdet,
obwohl das überhaupt nichts
mit der Diskussion zu tun hat,
dann verlinkt doch diese Person
einfach auf dieses Video,
auf genau diese Stelle,
wo ich jetzt sage:
Hallo, du siehst
dieses Video gerade,
weil du ein Ad-hominem-Argument
verwendet hast.
Es sei denn natürlich,
der Charakter einer Person
oder die Person an sich hat etwas
direkt mit der Streitfrage zu tun!
Also, auch "ad hominem"
muss man kritisch betrachten!
Nr.2:
Die meisten Menschen interessieren
sich für Naturwissenschaften!
Das könnte ich behaupten, wenn ich
nur Kommentare von "maiLab" lese.
Aber dabei unterliege
ich einem sogenannten:
Sprich: Ich sehe nur das,
was ich in meiner Blase sehe,
und kann das nicht zwingend
auf die allgemeine Gültigkeit
für den Rest der Welt übertragen!
Die meisten Menschen interessieren
sich für Naturwissenschaften!
Die Wahrheit, Freunde der Sonne:
Wir sind hier einfach nur
eine kleine Versammlung
von 'n paar Science-Freaks.
Mit Betonung auf "Freaks"!
Cheers!
Nr.3:
Wir sind immer auf der Suche
nach Begründungen, nach Ursachen.
Doch dabei sind wir manchmal
ein bisschen voreilig.
Es gibt 2 häufige Fallen:
1. Korrelation
ist nicht gleich Kausalität!
Zwischen Musikgeschmack
und Schulnoten
besteht hier nur eine Korrelation,
also nur ein Zusammenhang,
nicht unbedingt eine Kausalität,
also eine Ursache.
2. Die "Post hoc,
ergo propter hoc"-Falle:
Es passierte danach, deswegen
wurde es auch dadurch verursacht.
Ich habe zuerst Globuli genommen, und
dann gingen meine Kopfschmerzen weg.
Deswegen habe ich das
auch den Globuli zu verdanken.
Das ist eine mögliche Begründung, ja.
Aber das ist
noch kein hinreichender Beweis!
Ich kann leider nicht die Zeit
zurückdrehen, keine Globuli nehmen
und schauen, wie meine Kopfschmerzen
dann verlaufen wären.
Nr.4:
Z.B.:
Die Mai sagt in ihren Videos
immer die Wahrheit.
Woher weißt du das?
Weil sie das in ihren Videos sagt!
Das, Freunde der Sonne, ist:
Eine Begründung,
die sich im Kreis dreht.
Ich "begründe" eine Behauptung
mit der Annahme,
dass diese Behauptung stimmt.
Und das fällt
noch nicht mal so sehr auf,
wenn man für die Begründung
die Behauptung einfach
etwas umformuliert, wie z.B.:
Ich bin ein ehrlicher Mensch,
weil ich immer die Wahrheit sage
und niemals lüge.
Oder:
Ich denke sehr wissenschaftlich,
weil ich ein sehr gutes
kritisches Denkvermögen habe.
Ihr seht, was ich da mache:
Ich gebe eine "Begründung",
indem ich "weil" sage.
Aber was da kommt,
ist keine Begründung,
sondern nur meine ursprüngliche
Behauptung anders formuliert.
Und diese Behauptung
muss erst mal überprüft werden!
Nr.5:
Wenn ich jetzt behaupte:
Unser Universum,
mit allem, was es beinhaltet,
ist nur ein winziger Bestandteil,
eine Art Elementarteilchen
eines gigantischen Pfeifhasen!
(Pfiff)
Dann darf ich nicht sagen:
Und solange mir niemand
das Gegenteil beweist, nehme ich an,
das ist die Wahrheit!
Nein!
Die Beweislast liegt bei mir!
Wenn ich eine Behauptung aufstelle,
dann muss ich auch beweisen,
dass wir Teil eines gigantischen
Pfeifhasen sind. (Pfeifen)
Solange ich das nicht getan habe,
kann ich nicht erwarten,
dass irgendjemand anderes
diese Behauptung als Wahrheit
oder mögliche Wahrheit akzeptiert!
Nr.6:
Die Argumente eines Professors
oder einer Bundeskanzlerin
oder einer Chefin
sind nicht automatisch besser
oder glaubwürdiger
als die Argumente anderer Menschen.
"Autoritäten", schreibt Carls Sagen,
"haben in der Vergangenheit
Fehler gemacht
und werden das
auch in der Zukunft tun."
In der Wissenschaft
gäbe es gar keine Autoritäten,
sondern allenfalls, und das ist jetzt
auch sehr wichtig, Experten!
Expertise und Autorität
sind 2 verschiedene Sachen,
die oft zusammenhängen.
Aber es ist ganz wichtig, da kritisch
hinzuschauen und zu differenzieren:
Ein Doktortitel z.B. wird
verliehen für ein Fachwissen!
Weil sich jemand jahrelang
mit einem bestimmten Thema
auseinandergesetzt hat,
das erforscht hat.
Ein Doktortitel
hat in unserer Gesellschaft
aber auch etwas zu tun mit Prestige
oder mit 'nem bestimmten Status.
Das ist Autorität!
Das sollte bei einer kritischen
Diskussion keine Rolle spielen.
Die Expertise, die fachliche,
allerdings schon.
Nr.7:
"False Dichotomy"
heißt es auf Englisch,
auf Deutsch heißt es:
"Das falsche Dilemma"!
Das ist, wenn ich nur 2 Extreme
als Möglichkeiten annehme,
und alles in der Mitte ignoriere:
Entweder bist du vegan,
oder du hasst Tiere.
Entweder bist du Wissenschaftlerin,
oder du glaubst an Gott.
Wenn wir in Extremen denken
und Sachen in der Mitte ignorieren,
ist es auch klar, dass wir
viel emotionaler diskutieren.
Aaah!
Nr.8:
"Straw man" heißt's im Englischen:
"Strohmann",
gemeint ist Vogelscheuche!
Das ist eine Darstellung
eines Menschen,
die aber vereinfacht
und verzerrt ist.
Und genauso
ist ein "Strohmann-Argument"
die falsche Darstellung
eines Gegenargumentes,
indem ich es
vereinfache oder verzerre,
damit ich dieses Gegenargument
leichter angreifen kann.
Ich sage jetzt z.B.:
Unser kritisches Denken wird getrübt
von unseren persönlichen Meinungen
und Erwartungen.
Deshalb ist es wichtig,
dass wir unser kritisches Denken
immer wieder selbst überprüfen.
Wenn ich daraus 'n Strohmann
machen wollte, würde ich sagen:
Mai findet, dass andere Menschen
zu blöd sind, um logisch zu denken.
Was für Scheinargumente
und Logikfallen kennt ihr noch?
Und welche dieser 8,
die ich jetzt vorgestellt habe,
findet ihr am schwierigsten?
Ich finde, glaube ich,
Ad-hominem-Argumente
besonders schwierig,
für mich selbst. Also ich merke,
dass z.B., wenn ich mir
eine Rede von Trump anschaue,
dann rattert es
in meinem Kopf geradezu
vor lauter Ad-hominem-Argumenten.
Weil ich den Mann halt nicht mag,
nicht ausstehen kann!
Aber dann muss ich mich
da auch selbst erinnern,
mir das selbst bewusst machen,
diese Ad-hominem-Argumente
beiseite stellen und mich auf die
sachlichen Argumente konzentrieren!
Ja... die natürlich
auch nicht viel besser sind.
So viel jetzt erst mal
zum kritischen Denken.
Wie gesagt, die Liste der Logik-
fallen ist eigentlich noch länger
und Carl Sagan ist auch nicht
der einzige große kritische Denker.
D.h.: Falls ihr euch für dieses Thema
interessiert und sagt,
in Zukunft würdet ihr gerne noch mehr
dazu wissen, lasst es mich wissen.
Dann kann ich auch
noch mehr Videos dazu machen.
Wir sehen uns
erst mal nächsten Donnerstag.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.